I used to wait tables
for like 4 years.
And I will always remember
this one couple that
I served, cause they were just
on fire.
(screaming)
Not literally, of course,
but you could tell that
they were just unashamed,
freaks in the sheets, because when
I asked, "Can I get you something to drink?"
Uh, I'll take a coke please.
(gasp) You bad, bad boy~
But I love that memory
because..the lust was so..palpable
you know, you could literally slice
the sexual tension in the air.
And it always made me wonder,
"If soda was so bad..
what else turned her on?"
This is the second time I've worn this
shirt this week.
(gasp) You dirty, dirty birdy.
Hey.
I didn't take a shower today.
(Tssssss)
These vitamins have high-fructose
corn syrup in them.
(sensual music)
And like, everybody's weird, yeah we
can all accept that, we're all weird.
It's just a matter of finding someone
whose "weird" is compatible with yours.
And the way that these two interacted
over soda..
was so adorable and hilarious.
That it just goes to show,
no matter how freaky you are on the inside,
there is someone out there..
who just..gets you.
It really gave me belief in love.
It did. (chuckles)
I'll see you next week.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara